good morning John a very long time ago I
bought this this is called a softbox
it's a light that photographers and
videographers use to make nice soft
diffuse light I got this about 10 years
ago and I have used it and every
vlogbrothers video I filmed at home
since then until today because the bulbs
in this thing over the years have
started to go kaput and yes these are
the original 10 year old bulbs one of
these bulbs burned out doesn't turn on
anymore which is a thing that happened
once the the light fell over and one of
the bulbs broke so that's where one of
them is I had three working bulbs and
that was enough I guess and then a
couple of weeks ago I was filming and
then I left my office and then I came
back in and there was smoke in here
light bulbs are totally supposed to burn
out they're not supposed to catch on
fire so the base of one of the bulbs was
a little bit on fire took the bulb out
it hadn't broken it was just sparking
internally and I ordered some new lights
and then I didn't set them up because
like who's got time for these things
well yesterday another one of the bulbs
caught on fire over 10 years of using
these lights and two of them catch on
fire within two weeks of each shot
something must have gone wrong with the
electricity it must not be the bulbs
it's something else
has broken with this light in any case
you're now watching a video that is
filmed with an LED light it's a little
bit harsh right now but I think that I
can use another one and turn them both
down and that'll look a little nicer so
let's see how that looks you know they
say three-point lighting is best but to
is gonna have to do it on a beautifully
foolish endeavor comes out in four days
I'm very excited very nervous it has had
really good reviews so far so that has
taken some of the weight off but the
point is while my world was actually
literally a little bit on fire it's so
also figuratively so um I guess I'll
just run this video out with like things
you maybe should know one if you read
the first book but it was a while ago
and you've kind of forgotten I released
a recap video voiced by Kristen seed is
the audiobook narrator ever on a Hanks
channel you definitely should not watch
that video if you don't want to be
spoiled on the first book though the
audiobook cast has been announced and
there's a bunch of people on it the
reason why is that there's there's five
point-of-view characters then there are
also what are called epigraphs and these
are like bits of context that happen
between chapters so this is partial
transcript closed-door fundraiser in
Decatur Georgia with Senator William
Casey made up
and those bits are sometimes things that
need their own voice actor to
differentiate them from the rest of the
text I like to think about audio as a
different medium and how we can adjust
it to best serve the the needs of that
medium so we thought about that a lot
I'm really proud of what we came up with
there's also a book resource guide at
altas future dotnet it's got a book club
kit it's got character playlists it's
got zoom backgrounds all kinds of fun
stuff and the virtual book tour is still
happening which you can learn more about
a hankerin calm you bought a ticket for
the July 6th event that John and I are
doing together your ticket may have been
refunded and you have to buy it again
that's a complicated thing that I'm
sorry about so check your inbox for an
email from The Strand which is the
bookstore that we're doing it with to
make sure that you're still signed up
John I'm gonna be honest with you this
has been a really obviously stressful
time of my life but strangely I'm not
experiencing that much book stress I'm
really excited for this thing to get out
in the world I really appreciate all the
the feedback I've gotten from you that's
been really positive and from early
readers I was able to do podcast
sponsorships with a bunch of small and
dependent podcasts for the book and I've
gotten to be on a bunch of podcasts I
recorded a couple today I'm recording
one tomorrow if you listen to podcasts
it might be hard to miss me it really
has been fun it's been a lot and there's
a lot else going on at the same time but
I kind of set myself up for that kind of
situation why do I do that is a story
for another video when I just noticed on
my floor of my office which is extremely
filthy these are the actual last sheets
of the book that I did my edits on the
most common note when I'm editing myself
is the word loose loose I don't know
what I even mean by that but you don't
want it to be loose alright John well I
will see you on Tuesday the day that a
beautifully foolish endeavor is
officially on sale